all right so now all the trailers so the
summer movies are coming out and they're
all worth talking about but one caught
my eye namely the Rise of the Planet of
the Apes yep we're getting a reboot of
the Planet of the Apes and they're
starting at square one how did the
monkeys take us over cuz it James Franco
of course I don't know if I see Franco
as a scientist type you think the guy
really cracked down in school takes his
life seriously I see him is really fun
adventurous pothead guy I'm just saying
and although this trailer tells look
cool there's a part of it that makes me
think deep blue sea with mammals are a
drug allows the brain to repair itself
we call it a cure
whenever I see that premise for the rest
of my life I will always see deep blue
sea there's just no stopping it and what
was the name of that drug we call it
cure the cure are you just naming off
random eighties bands that you love if
you're gonna name a drug after an 80s
band to impress investors go big we call
it smell the glove by spinal tap hey
fake albums by fake bands count so after
that the monkeys get smart they break
out and then you know all hits the
fan the music swelling and you see the
monkeys taking over they surround that
poor dude that's probably gonna get his
ass kicked but what I want to know is
how is the military unable to stop this
uprising I know the monkeys are smart
and all that but you know we we have
guns and tanks and helicopters and jets
you can take on Stein Hawking Dawkins
Darwin whoever you consider awesome and
smart put him on the firing squad and
I'm pretty sure they're gonna drop when
you pull the trigger but if the movie
has a good explanation for it all the
more epic and what about that one scene
where the gorilla jumps onto the
helicopter I mean everything has
something jump onto a helicopter
nowadays I think they capped when Bruce
Willis took out a helicopter with a car
and I was like you know what done he
wins even if he hated the movie you
gotta admit that was awesomely
unrealistically awesome but there is a
scene where I'm monkeys about to do what
Harry Potter could not and that is take
out Malfoy The Wizarding World thanks
you you genius Abe upon everything you
see my favorite scene in the entire
trailer is this scene right here where
the Apes all like he doesn't say
anything no words you can just tell he's
just smart and thinking it out unless
it's a scene in the movie before he
starts getting the smart serum in which
case I'm gonna look like an I'll
tell you what sold me on this movie it
wasn't as much the trailer the second
half of the trailers really cool but
it's this concept art right here that's
what did it right there that should be
the poster
not you know that boring thing in any
case this summer's looking like it's
going to be awesome have you seen the
Planet of the Apes trailer if not I put
the link below go
check it out come back here comment
below let me know and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more cuz
smart monkey says so